[Music]
happy to be here
[Music]
viewer discretion is advised bad girls
[Music]
bad girls bad girls what you gonna do
what you gonna do when they come for you
bad girls bad girls what you gonna do
what you gonna do
[Music]
feminist cops is filmed on location with
the brave strong women of law
enforcement all suspects are innocent
until proven guilty in a court of law
one officer down corners with the main
requesting backup going to perform a
tactical reload
[Music]
seconds
[Applause]
[Music]
bad girls bad girls what you gonna do
what you gonna do when they hope for
[Music]
appropriations
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to cultural appropriation
month
[Music]
uh uh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
stranger
[Music]
that's a sip of a slow news day and for
those of you who've been watching with
us for a long time
you know what that means a good chance
we'll be banned
and it's not our fault exciting there's
a strong chance
that we will not be here tomorrow also
we have that by the way that that bs uh
privacy violation from youtube which we
need to solve right now remember yeah
the person who sat down for the change
my mind yeah and then uh for about 25
minutes and then complained saying it
was a violation of privacy even though
he consented on camera spelled his name
and signed a release so apparently
youtube doesn't care about the law hmm
i think he went for a job interview and
they're like
is this you
no no no
it's just just so stupid yes why would
you want this thrown out well i watched
myself and i'm an idiot yeah well up
until this moment i believe that i came
off
swimmingly and today you've proven me
wrong
also i'm a workaholic that's my greatest
weakness does that help you are not
burger king material
no flipping burgers we can't have you
ruining our lgbt pride month with two
tops or two bottoms to our whopper no
[Laughter]
did you see that yes yeah i saw yeah
i love the klm one where it's the the
seat belt buckles and it's like yeah all
all of those make you die in a crash the
only one that works is the male and
female right
takes two hands to handle the upper so
it's a slow news day that means that you
can watch us on rumble monday through
thursday 10 a.m eastern monday through
thursday or of course on mug club we
have an additional hour of show uh like
uh today we're playing what the flag oh
with our in in-house mime
well
so we'll see what happens there band and
there was something else oh well well
hold on when i announce dave uh my
question i guess to you today before we
move on because this is something that i
think you'll probably answer before you
watch the rest of the show
so if you're watching live
wait and then if you're not watching if
you're not watching live pause it don't
cheat
don't fast forward use a cheat sheet
treat it like a scantron card
what do you think is the most
crime-ridden city in america right now
comment below i don't know why i feel
like i'm coming in loud on my headphones
it could be that i had an ear thing and
now it's gone no it's just my own
headphones i hate the sound of my voice
i turn them about every day to see if i
can damage trouble controlling the
volume of my voice
so
he is before we get to that he is
wonderful you know him you love him he
has a voice for radio
uh and a face for the penitentiary
gerald a how are you i was wondering who
you were gonna introduce with that
thanks i think i'm doing well how are
you i'm okay yeah yeah i'm all right
okay well a little low on the on the
sleep but uh this happens i feel like
you're about to get mad at something
probably there's always a low grade
irritation stories we're about to cover
yeah we're gonna be talking about crime
just to let you know we'll be talking
about you subsidizing organizations now
these transgender organizations their
newest they want reparations
what
uh this is true yeah we do remember all
the transgender slaves yes yes they were
promised 40 acres and a dilator that's
right and some duct tape and uh
and some what is it luporn lupron i
don't know whatever it is they used to
chemical castrate sex offenders it's
puberty blockers now it's fine a
different thing we don't know since we
don't know the long-term effects let's
just roll the dice so this is something
that's actually going on they're
complaining about uh anti-trans
colonialization
[Music]
that's yeah
and here's the thing
this is going to be taught in your
schools
look this is important because people
not too long ago said oh come on this is
just a fringe well look and when people
say let me just preface this because
sometimes people say why are you so
obsessed with the whole or the trans
seems like you're overly concerned with
really hold on a second the person
responding to the president who made it
one of his first practices to come in
and by the way now ban uh funding for
schools for school lunches if they don't
allow boys to use the girls restroom
you're saying that us responding to that
is being overly concerned with it we
turned our head around and then you
entirely restructured society based on
um non-science
so that's why we're talking about it and
uh the quickest man on his feet
the quickest wit in the west uh he is
going to be in um
june uh i sorry i thought we were
talking about colorado she's going to be
in des moines iowa june 10th and june
11th
uh dave landau ahoy
i like how you said it like we've never
met yeah
today i didn't know this was new to me i
didn't i thought we were i thought we
were doing no uh we had switched it
right after because i'm there this
weekend oh okay des moines des moines
iowa the longest uh week i ever spent
was one night in des moines yes corn
huskers if you stay in des moines uh and
uh that's nebraska
yeah who cares your show if you stay in
des moines there's only one hotel and
it's i don't know wait am i thinking of
bettendorf think about that never mind
it's all the same
des moines one of the quad cities i
couldn't yeah
yes yeah anyway
i believe it's bettendorf there's only
one hotel it's a casino and they just
ask you would you like to be in the
north tower or the south tower i was
like i don't know
they said we'll put you in the south
tower turns out the north tower was
entirely remodeled like a hyatt and the
south tower was certain death yes yes
which is the same price like would you
like the tower filled with natives yes
the extended stay version
yeah all right
excited stay's actually nice
more like the super 8 version whatever
yes the red roof inn yeah
the week long hooker pads yes by the way
major fall tour dave and i will be
announcing uh next week as we finalize
these dates could be coming to your city
so go to lightroom with crowder.com tour
stay posted uh yeah these are gonna be
some big some big big shows big ass
shows all right
let's go to this really quick let's just
let's just get right into it so um these
trans activists right now and i have to
be careful to not use words
uh chris ruffo uh he he got his hand on
some leaked videos from a trans
conference and i'll explain you this
isn't just some fringe minority this is
something that is becoming mainstream
and some of these organizations receive
subsidies which is uh deeply disturbing
you think the founding father pardon my
language if you have kids
i think the founding fathers would have
stood for this [ __ ] think about the
boston tea party think about what that
was that was basically an uber eats
processing fee for tea
do you think they would do you think
they would be okay with subsidizing
trans organizations that want to host
drag shows for kids i don't know so
their wigs were silly yes yeah they did
have syphilis it depends on the guy yeah
it's true i guess they work tight how
much brain rot you had everything old is
new again
so chris ruffo leaked these videos
that's a trans conference and uh now
their new crusade
is and the reason i'm telling you about
this now is because it's going to be
tomorrow's mainstream there's going to
be a college course taught on this if
it's not already probably is of course
there is uh
the decolonization
of gender
we have to acknowledge that the center
of the
transphobic colonial order
that we are talking about that has
erased this history is warfare
and it is warfare against indigenous
people
myself
it's been a constant you know struggle
under colonialism not to accept and
affirm myself
but to find acceptance and affirmation
and understanding outside of myself um
it was colonial society that
influenced me to hate myself
to separate and fracture parts of my
identity talk about it your uncle tried
to kiss you at a barbecue my reflection
and how i saw myself and how that self
related to everything else around me and
the relationship
to myself and to the land i really see
all gender dysphoria as being a product
of colonialism ah yes you really look
like you live off the land who can
forget transgender gothic
right
yes it's colonial we all learned about
in high school about the uh the trail of
queers and the uh horrible uh colonial
you know they just came in right away
took it out on the
the navajo yes
we could forget wounded [ __ ] yeah
you know if you're gonna get wounded
that's a bad place it is a bad place to
take one well that's where they landed
at uh splitteth [ __ ] yes i guess that i
guess it still would be wounded knee
wouldn't it yes
clock i guess
yeah
[Laughter]
this is where we are look this is and
you know
we have hold on do we have another video
that we're going to show in a second on
that because if you're oh we have many
okay good good so i want to draw
particular attention to not just the
person talking but if you're missing the
little sub boxes below where they're
like
doing this to clap and this guy's doing
like you're missing half of the fun in
the video yeah so just make sure you
look at it they basically have a
transgender real life sebastian
as well
how do you know it's a boy dave i want
to be where the trunnies are
so much better uh do better women get
wetter little seagulls like i know what
this is this is a this is a this is a
remedy for monkey box
[Laughter]
look i told you it's a slow news day but
here's the thing
these
people
uh are
uh
actually
trying to see the
i'm trying to
okay when you look at everything through
the prism of victimhood that's how you
end up with something that is so far off
the beam that these people have no i
there's no self-awareness like hey you
know what maybe maybe it's kind of crazy
to see
uh the whole transphobia as the
byproduct of colonialism
uh maybe you know you could see it
through the lens of the slave traders
from west africa wouldn't have had much
use for you
no unless you count
if there was no girls there were no
girls yeah then this person's in line
and comes up you're like uh what else
you got right yeah i mean they were like
well there's the sea cow which we think
are mermaids we've been having sex with
those for some time yeah what about this
thing with the nose ring perfect i'll
take the manatee
i'll pass there anything with a blowhole
i don't know i don't know yeah yeah yes
but i guess
amis
d i don't know we can go all day
and we should stop so the conference
included by the way uh a few groups ship
goes like 10 feet
just go back rowing is hard you just
hear a splash ah
colonialist [ __ ] so tired gosh can i
tan
why are you so tired estrogen
so uh there were groups that by the way
were receiving uh uh
funny so they were running programs for
minors just to be clear at this
conference and these were there were
several of these groups who are
receiving taxpayer funding and these
groups include these are the actual
groups all references available with
crowder.com the lavender rights project
the black trans task force a movie
gender justice league a movie utopia
washington
and then this other group traction uh
should be known formerly known as
friction
honestly black trans task force was my
favorite comic book as a kid yes they
would all link super powers it was
pretty good they become one giant right
supergiant who could forget new shaft
or ghost shaft the sequel
here they're they're these programs are
for minors remember when they said
they're not going after your kids we we
talked about this yesterday you can go
to uh to lot of credit.com club to see
all the banned episodes in the archive
one of them was because we said look the
transgender the lgbtqaip community is
targeting your children i think the
title of the show was they're coming for
your kids yeah and they said you can't
say that that's that's hate speech well
okay we tried to warn you and this is
the problem when you have big tech fact
checking saying you can't say that
transgender
uh activists are coming for your
children
and now they have your children and
you're paying for it with your tax
dollars yeah we're so far beyond the
scope of legitimate government think
about it one point people don't taxation
without representation there was an
argument about the unconstitutionality
of the income the federal income tax and
there still is yeah if we're gonna argue
about that shouldn't we just you know
shouldn't we we just put on the shelf
for a little bit funding
gender justice league and black trans
task force through your property taxes
yeah gen
gender justice league it has super and
bat and wonder yes
and aqua
that's just his favorite color
you're just naming what
that's
i mean what is wrong with that what are
you how are you just
we're a justice wha why i i think i'm a
boy oh no no we can no i don't know
you only think that
because of james madison you know what
now that i think about it well i did
read some of his uh auxiliary writings
the earlier works really threw me for a
loop yes they really did
but my birth certificate lies
they classified you you were assigned
that at birth no it was recognized what
can you imagine being a doctor and now
i'd just be like yeah do whatever the
hell you want whatever you want you just
go in room to room for some 400 pounds
you're like yep you're brave good luck
the other room is like i want estrogen
no cancer risk here
throwing pills at a five-year-old you're
like enjoyed never growing up yep enjoy
your tits young man
singing the peter pan i never want to
grow up your wish is my command here you
go granted there you go yeah enjoy it
i don't know why shootings are up god
bless you yes no idea who could have
seen this coming oh no that's right it's
the ar-15 yes oh yes it's them yes
here's my prescription pad just take it
whatever you need here's my prescription
pad and a stencil so you can write my
sick just copy my signature go right
here look i'll put whatever you want i
write it sloppy anyway to not get sued
but i don't even care anymore i don't
care what did you sue for medical
malpractice i just injected a kid with
nine mrna vaccines and now he has a
third nipple and a head like the
elephant man so you know what
really the oath used to be first do no
harm now it's uh i believe your guess is
as good as mine yes
so i'm just going to write myself a
prescription for 300 vicodin go home and
make a milkshake yes
the old red wine vicodin milkshake
it's medicine so here's another these
activists here they're actually blaming
european colonialism
for the invention of the gender binary
okay
um it's colonialism that's preventing
you know
chicks with mustaches in in in
polymer penises from being recognized as
feminine this is what they're actually
arguing and they are
bringing this
to minors
yeah i just want to live in a world
where um
you know if i call myself a unicorn i'd
be that
and people will be well with that um i
really see all gender dysphoria as being
a product of colonialism i 100
you know
want to still be able to look in the
mirror
and
see every part of myself as a woman see
every part of myself unfortunately
you know trans woman a beautiful being
my mustache you know my all of my facial
hair my
untrim brows you know like my my fat ass
like my my belly
my big dick like you know everything i
want i want to be able to see every part
of myself she's going to be a shallow
guy about it oh yeah i want to be called
non-binary transform my whole life no i
don't i just want to be called randy
aisha well which is it randy or ayesha
character
they would come up with wakanda they
would come up with pokemon trainer they
would come up with whatever was on their
heart and i was like that is the world i
want to see where we're calling
ourselves cyborgs we're calling
ourselves whatever we need
to
feel good about ourselves like cyborgs
well please tell me skynet's falling
if there is any justice in the world
terminator will be here soon give me
your bike your boots and your die later
[Laughter]
wait do you want my pants are they cute
[Laughter]
comes up with an error he's scanning
he's like i cannot do this we want to
identify as cyborgs by the way do you
have any idea how racist ai is going to
be i think they would they would just
wipe you out but did you hear what she
said when i talk to my youths when i
talk to my youths these are the words
that they come up with i want us to be
known as whatever we want the other
person said if i want to be called a
unicorn i want people to be okay with
that and like oh gosh
yeah it looks like a.i just made
nonsense and he's like sorry yes right i
don't know how to make people like this
is your sequel to white chicks it's
black things yeah
and then
it's not enough for them to just live in
this way
they demand this i want to live in the
world where everyone accepts it and they
used to say that we were straw manning
when we would bring up look this is not
only a slippery slope but you have some
people out there who want to identify as
unicorns like that's just absurd
you have these people who are taxpayer
subsidized targeting the youths utes
with
we should be allowed to be called
unicorns and cyborgs and the guy said i
want what do you say i want to be called
something and aisha a guy's name on asia
randy
randy and aisha i often confuse the two
names yes well
like i said i was talking to randy no no
that's that's it it was you know what it
was randy aisha and by the way i love
how uh it's toxic masculinity until a uh
female appropriating masculine culture
just lists all the stereotypes i like my
untrimmed brows my gross mustache my fat
ass my all these my big dick wouldn't
you tell wouldn't that be toxic
masculinity oh because you're faking it
it's beautiful and brave just like every
not every but most transgender male
individuals who become females all of a
sudden all of the gender stereotypes of
woman womanhood come back into play i
know what it's like to be a woman why
because i dress like a barbie doll oh
okay you listen to a few aqua songs
great you know all the splendor that is
womanhood
well my my saying my big dick is really
showing your your bluff and gender poker
right because you're like oh my you know
eight inch soft [ __ ] yes
he's about to grab all the chips until
the even crazier transgender pansexuals
like wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
straight flush
that's every single poker game if ever
you're watching a poker game in film
when they if they reach for the chips
with one hand it means they don't win
because someone else is going to go ah
and then it's a full arm scoop
that's all i know about poker well the
reality to all of this is there are
people where this is a real problem or
it's and maybe it's not a problem maybe
this is who they are whatever but it it
it's not all of you there's just too
many of you doing this so it's a trend
that's the reality let's just put it out
you discount
the confounding fact
the co-factors of colonialism oh that i
forgot yes yes we know what it was
buckled shoes yes and the pilgrims
buckled head who the hell needs a buckle
on a hat right
[Laughter]
absurd maybe they had migraines yeah
that's true well if that works let me
know
i'll buckle my hands they weren't even
useful you couldn't even use them they
did not actually tighten anything they
were just decorative right yeah you know
what a decorative you know what the
problem is
yes this hat is not heavy enough no like
you know what i need to lean forward
what are you not getting scoliosis
enough from the fact that we have no
vitamins i have extra buckles well use
that then yeah
but meanwhile they're walking around
with pants that just keep falling like i
can't keep these knickers
what are you wearing
spelled with a cake and so i was like
what did you say you're a quiet gay of
start yes
[Laughter]
you better shut up for you're about to
be 12 years ago what if i don't want to
wear the buckle
now here's the thing i made spenders if
what you're hearing sounds like insane
ramblings
it's because they are
uh and they admitted they basically
acknowledge as much at one point one of
these presenters again who's receiving
your tax dollars and targeting your
children this is why parents if you put
your kids in public schools and if you
do not have some kind of an ad block or
whatever it is cyber sitter
it's almost child abuse because this is
being pumped at them 24 7. and dare i
say it in many ways this can be just as
dangerous and corrosive as pornography
and by the way
often these kinds of conferences include
uh pornography if not also advocacy for
pornography uh because how do you grow
children without it so at one point one
of the presenters actually talks about
hearing the screams
of his ancestors from nature as a child
and no one says that's crazy
for me when i was growing up colonialism
looked a lot like my first introduction
to queenism looked a lot like
me waking up
at you know four in the morning five in
the morning
every morning to you know
sounds of you know my ancestors
screaming from outside my window
um coming from the the ground coming
from the earth
um and nature outside you know like
waking me up to tell me that like hey
there there's work to be done
no those were the the souls of all the
bodies you buried after wearing them as
a skin suit
[Laughter]
that wasn't your ancestors that was the
guy in the well who you give lotion to
in a basket
we also just built a pool on an indian
burial ground
twice we had to make multiple movies to
cover it yeah
and it wasn't it wasn't colonial
sentiment it was just hey
stop
every morning at 4 00 a.m i hear voices
yelling outside that i need to wake up
again they're my ancestors from the
ground yeah telling me to leave your
honor the tv i rest my case and by the
way of course we would never never
insinuate in any capacity no and not in
general but that this individual
specifically correct might be dealing
with some kind of mental issues because
it would be wrong to say so considering
that z says uh the screams were what
radicalized
z because uh
it was the screams that radicalized them
but
also i should note because the parents
weren't there so that's what really
radicalized me at a very young age
amongst many other things uh you know
hearing those screams every morning is
what really radicalized me because there
are things that most other folks around
me including my my mother could not hear
um and they are things that they they
you know that did not affect those
individuals in the source
um
and i carried that i followed those
screams you know into the woods as a
child um
my parents you know didn't really like
watch me very much apparently sorry
should i say somebody watch me very much
uh growing up so i often wandered into
the woods and was taught
um by my ancestors in those woods you
know in in the forms of nature spirits
um in the forms of elementals and the
forms of you know natural deities and
old gods you know while i was out there
you know i was taught many things where
are the people who
you know condescend to christians and
say oh you're flying spaghetti monster
even though like unlike hearing uh the
screams in
into the woods uh jesus was a historical
figure certainly at the very least
whether you're a christian or not you
have to acknowledge acknowledge the
fundamental changing of western
civilization due to his impact even
virtues now that we recognize that we're
not virtues before jesus christ like
mercy and modern christendom what i
really find concerning and this does to
me encapsulate a lot of issues we're
dealing with is
the person there says you know the
screen my mother couldn't hear the
things that i hear it assumes that
they're real it assumes that this person
is
is is correct it's just well my
perceived reality is reality that's not
true and nowhere outside of this
movement which by the way is
anti-science anti-it's anti-family it's
anti-western civilization but it's also
anti-science and it's anti-reality
nowhere else do you get to put your hand
on a hot stove and say my reality is
it's not scalding my hand or stand in
traffic and say my reality is there are
no cars on this freeway but here you get
to say well my reality must be reality
so these other people didn't hear the
screams which made me feel really
isolated that's because there were no
screams from your ancestors yeah
and by the way they probably weren't
your ancestors your grandfather's
probably named lyle
it's like
it's like a beautiful mind without that
beautiful part right well
by the way i mentioned the hollywood
squares down at the bottom for all of
the people that were snapping i want you
to notice if somebody later on go back
and watch this or if you're watching
rewind this and look at the bottom
they're like
yeah they're like
they stop snapping and they're like you
just need medication
these are people willing ready and able
to applaud whatever things they see on
the screen are like oh damn and by the
way you followed screams into the woods
by the way when you're a kid why'd you
follow screams right that was comforting
to you yeah exactly i heard screams in
the woods and thought hey i'll go check
it out see what they have to teach me
better than my home life father the
voices of the night phantom of the
cockra
the voices of the night isn't that the
song i don't know ghost of
[Laughter]
what's odd about me is let's say you
believe this right and you did go in
there so you're you do believe in the
demonic which means that you have to
believe in some sort of spiritual
afterlife now if you believe you're born
into some other body that means you have
to believe in some kind of a soul right
because you're not it's not your brain
then working it means that you have a
spirit that was born into another body
which means you would have to believe in
the demonic so how can you be
anti-religion and then believe all this
stuff it doesn't make sense they're just
anti-religion that actually you know uh
has some kind of moral accountability
that's what's so strange though right
it's like it would have but he for him
to know that that's somewhat wrong right
they would have to he would have to have
some moral accountability to some degree
to realize that that's and everybody
like gerald pointed out
below him that we're like
oh yeah when you've lost bruce valanche
yeah yeah well he's like i'm sorry he's
gone yeah you know the the specter that
this gentleman feels when randy newman
stops the piano and can't play what's
going on
and then it was in the woods and what i
can't that guy ain't got a reason to
live
because he's short because he's crazy
the specter he fears the most is the
ghost of christmas coocher
not getting phil's wigs
instead of pointing to a grave it's just
a ghost of christmas future it's just
pointing to a gay rave bar and then
right next to it is the grave of
everyone who attended so look here's the
thing this is also this is designed to
tear at the fabric if they can't do it
through the constitution this is very
similar to what you see with the second
amendment right so we can't do it
constitutionally so we'll do some things
by executive order and chip chip chip
chip chip chip away if they can't do
away with western civilization by just
telling people hey don't you hate
western civilization and free enterprise
and freedom and most people say no so
what they try and do this is the marxist
ideology is they try and tear at the
very fabric of what has created western
civilization namely by the way uh the
family which requires gender roles and
i'm not going to play this game of
gender and sex they were entirely
interchangeable until modern gender
theory which was from some start you can
go back to simone de bevoir and french
existentialism they'll try and say well
some tribes had some different genders
okay fine but a that's not entirely true
and b
you still couldn't get away with this
they wouldn't have thought that this was
normal but let me read you some of this
from you look at the marxist philosophy
the destruction of capitalism white
supremacy patriarchy imperialism and
white european land
ownership so that's the goal it's also
by the way it's it's this whole thing is
a scam
just to be clear
remember black lives matter remember we
were all saying like this is a scam
they're getting so much money and
they're clearly not doing anything with
it they were saying defund the police
fund us by the way smash that like
button i should say if you're watching
this on youtube right now and uh you can
also go and listen on audio because we
have people listening on audio yeah on
apple and on spotify but a lot of it
doesn't make sense today if you're
listening on audio i apologize and the
visual aids are very helpful
so literally deeply disturbing yes
one of the two
soul rattlingly terrifying
they it's not enough for them to just
live remember tolerance now it's forced
acceptance now it's forced
acknowledgment of a false reality
and ultimately the scam is what do they
want
it's a scam by the way reparations for
black people in the united states i'm
against that but
they want now reparation this is not a
joke i'm so glad i'm glad i have the
clip
reparations for trans people
so folks watch um i think another way
that you can support people who are
doing community work if you have like
access to generational wealth if you're
white um and your parents you know like
have like a savings account that is you
know very much so connected to slavery
and land theft you know pay people pay
people directly give them the money so
they can have the financial security in
order to rest and appeal and to connect
um with their communities in a way that
they wouldn't have to because they've
been working because they've been doing
this work we've always been doing this
work being productive and whatever i
think randy brought this up before but
like pay that money you know reparations
like pay that money to us now because we
need that we don't have especially for
black indigenous folks we don't have
like um
you know a safety net in order to take
that time to heal um and it can be a
privilege for some so um if you have
those resources share them so let me
just list there some of the things
i know some of the concepts by the way
was that austin power's chest hair i
wasn't sure what i was looking i thought
it was a shadow but it also looked like
chest hair
we don't want to speak out of turn i
don't know but at this point this is the
problem
your guess is as good as it's whatever
whatever you're doing we don't care it's
immutable but let's go through that for
a second it's rep if you have money in
your savings account you should give
money and of course what they really
mean is the government should force you
to take money from your savings account
so boom right there we're talking about
policy we're talking about changing the
way that civilization exists and then
it's you should give money to trans
individuals okay because we've been
forced to work so what we want to do is
pay reparations remember it used to be
pay reparations to try and balance the
playing field now they are demanding to
pay reparations to people
who are not a race by the way to
transgender individuals so that they can
be unproductive
while you pay for it hey by the way if
everyone does that
how are you going to pay for anything
if everyone just rests
and again this is i will say this this
is a bastardization of as a christian
what we believe to be important look
christians believe in rest yeah people
try and say the unions gave you a
weekend no you know who was uh god
and i was like yeah you rest on the
seventh day why because that really took
a lot out of me making people in the
whole universe you're like okay you know
what you've earned yourself a day of
rest these people want to rest always
and they want you to pay for it and
they're
indoctrinating an entire generation with
this that's how you do away with western
civilization you have an entire
generation of people who grow up
thinking well you know what you should
have to pay for someone else to do
nothing because
a very very long time ago
some colonialists landed and um they
committed genocide against chicks with
dicks
i didn't know that i have a phd in these
studies that's where we are headed and
they're not even hiding the ball anymore
the motivations are completely did i say
transparent
almost as transparent by the way as the
transparent transparent
[Music]
did you eat your vegetables and brush
your teeth
yes i did
okay good
[Music]
this brings us to by the way as they
push harder and harder um he did do i
meant to talk about this earlier but i'm
sure you've seen this and many of you
have seen this film
uh matt walsh over at daley wire has
created a documentary uh what is a woman
and is this the clip with this one
yes uh a professor
and it just this just goes to show you
blonde
yeah and i want to tell you something
i'm smart enough
okay
but when i came into this you know i
came into this i was just an actor and a
comedian up until about 21 years old and
then i was sort of thrust into the
political
arena because i happened to be more
right-leaning and that got me banned
from these clubs and colleges early on
and it forced me to examine okay am i
willing to continue down this path and
actually be authentic to who i am right
live my true self
um
the issue that we run into you know what
look is
i was gonna say no i was gonna say just
roll the clip here's the thing i thought
before for example i went to fox news or
i thought before i would go and
interview professors
that these people at ivy league
universities
that the lawyers that the senators
that the that the judges right in the
highest courts that they somehow had
information that we didn't right you
like to assume sort of like when you're
a kid and you assume that the parents
have all the answers and then once
you're a parent you realize you're just
a kid with no answers and you're faking
it a lot of the time
that's a lot of these people that's a
lot of these elites that's a lot of the
in the universities they'll try and beat
you over the head with their degrees not
only do they know nothing much of the
time they often know less than nothing
because they've unlearned the truth you
see this with a lot of people who are in
the highest offices of politics in the
land not only does joe biden know
nothing he knows less than nothing
because he hasn't had to earn an honest
dollar in 50 years not only does aoc
know nothing she knows less than nothing
compared to a business owner because she
doesn't know what goes into actually
creating a business and it was a real
awakening for me where i would sit down
with people who were senior fellows at
think tanks and like i say
i'm smart enough
but i was far more educated meaning i
had taken time out of my day to learn
about these issues that these think tank
fellows and sometimes professors
were teaching
and it was startling how little they
know and i think that's important to set
the concept here for this clip matt
walsh daily wire the film is what is a
woman with this
professor and look at the condescending
tone and then complete lack of logic
we're talking about gender and sex and
there's a lot of controversies there if
we're talking about a trans woman has
all of the male
physical characteristics so would that
not be
a male then couldn't we plainly say
this person is a male well well i guess
it's like
why are you asking the question i think
i i want to understand sort of why
that's so important so if someone tells
you to
sort of understand
reality
you know
i'm just trying to start by getting to
the truth you know
yeah i mean i'm really uncomfortable
with that language of like getting to
the truth again
lost boys because that it sounds
actually deeply transphobic to me um
and if you keep probing we're gonna stop
the interview i if i probe about what
the truth is you keep invoking the word
truth which is condescending and rude
well right but we're in a university
this is a place of understanding truth
isn't it or
absolutely we're we pursue truth and i'm
a social scientist and that's what i do
you just said the truth is transphobic
the that you would say that you're if
you're saying the truth is that i get to
say you're not a man show me your
genitalia that's transphobic i don't
want to see him as genitalia i i just
mean
someone can make a statement about
themselves that could be untrue like for
example if i
if i were to say that i'm a black man
could you
[Music]
would you accept that or would you be
skeptical
are you black are you afraid of american
are you bri racial
i'm a social scientist oh wait you
mispronounced useless oh my gosh you
just get an a on everything now right
yeah i think so by the way this uh a
movie that never needed to be made what
is a woman yeah in what world did we
think that that was a question that ever
needed to be answered i feel like we've
done this documentary over the course of
you know seven years with different
segments and it's just he just put it
all together and interviewed these
professors i'm so glad he did it yeah
it's what is a woman.com right where you
can go and yeah go watch it and watch it
but you here's how you know that it's
completely false and it's completely
ridiculous and just a left movement
he's defensive immediately yeah he
doesn't have a conversation he doesn't
have a talking point even right he just
goes immediately to that makes me very
uncomfortable you would even ask me such
a thing right like he's one of the
knights who say truth right it's like no
i'm just asking you if i had a female
genitalia would i be a woman i don't
know how to answer that what am i a
professor yeah what am i a gender
studies professional
what do i what am i
social scientist oh sometimes i'm not a
doctor and by the way if the doctor
answers that we'll sue the doctor yes we
will so
by the way if anybody comments on that
we will ban them yes are you are you
black man and then he goes are you
biracial it's like so you're not buying
the black man thing then right yeah
you're looking right at me and you went
right to biracial because you don't
believe i'd be a fully black man so you
just answered the question right the
question yes
though he's like oh crap oh shoot
oh no logic yeah it's like yes it's my
kryptonite can you say it's a magnet
he's wearing a lot of logic lockets oh
there's logic in his earrings seriously
that's just the stupid thing about
superman how does everyone have
kryptonite that's true that's a lot of
supposed to be rare yeah it's not that
rare on earth
he's wearing those moisture-wicking
kryptonite undergarments oh
he asked me a question i've i've never
been in this situation before as a
teacher he asked me what the truth is
i'm melting wouldn't you have a better
answer prepared like you know what the
interview's going to be about and you'd
be like look i don't want to sound like
an idiot wouldn't you be asked this i
don't know all the time yeah
you would think so well yeah but those
people get banned from the classroom
but don't worry there's no silencing and
this is the thing too and but we'll have
to just move on from that we won't do
the wahpo article because we're running
late today we'll go to the golden state
of crime but this is the thing when
people talk about cancel culture they
get it wrong
i don't like the term cancel culture the
issue that we're dealing with too and
it's important to note at one point in
time right when we would do or you'd
appear doing terrestrial radio to like
promote a club gig so for the many of
you watching terrestrial radio is if you
hit the power button in your car which
you've never done
uh it plays you know there's still
something playing and it's regulated by
something called the fcc at that point
you kind of had a list at least of words
that you could or you couldn't say and
that's if you look at the supreme court
case and george carlin um
the issue now isn't even the audience
being outraged that's not like cancel
cultures they will often say oh there
are consequences for your actions no no
the problem is people in positions of
power wielding it disproportionately
in order to try and affect public
perception despite the fact that it
flies in the face of it it's not people
looking to ban matt walsh's film it's
not the average citizen it's not such an
outcry that us discussing the fact that
they are targeting your children needs
to be removed it's people in positions
of power in big tech in the educational
establishment and in politics who are
deciding that they will exert that to
remove opinions they don't like we need
to be really clear about that these
aren't consequences of the free market
at work these are consequences of
corruption and abuses of executive power
whether it's a professor or the
president of the united states
withholding funding to schools regarding
lunches if they don't allow chicks with
dicks in the uh boys room or vice versa
that's the problem yeah it's just
showing that people are pawns and this
is a giant game politics politicians
don't care about you right this is all a
game that's all this leads down to and
don't send your kids to college yeah
really don't there's no it's not that in
college especially well where i'd love
to know what college because i'm not i
haven't seen one that isn't like this in
a very long time yeah no i think i mean
there are online colleges where you can
mitigate some of the damage and i think
you should be looking at trades i think
that a university degree is less
relevant than ever you really think that
your professor has access to information
that you don't on your phone
no why do you have to buy his textbook
remember that when you got into college
no you have to buy you have to buy uh
this the the test is going to be uh
based on what you read in my 450 book
yeah yeah where do i get it only in the
bookstore here yes for an insane amount
of money so every other good luck 150
pages is 25 that's correct and yours is
450
don't worry you can sell it back at the
end of the year for six bucks yes
to resell for 450 i will autograph it
for you it loses 90 percent of its value
uh once it rolls out of the library yes
you will need a wheelbarrow because we
printed in very large fonts so it looks
larger than it is lots of pictures yep
but good news i'm a terrible writer yes
ah you'll be falling asleep before you
know it even better news i'm a worse
teacher
[Laughter]
good luck why can't why couldn't the guy
just say well i feel that some people
are born uh male and female that's just
what the standard practice is and you
know yeah the world and some identify as
something else that's all you really
have to say that's a decision if you say
identify
well don't they say it themselves
no they say that it's not a decision
because then that flies in the face of
the language that well they try to
assign right your sex at birth as
opposed to simply recognize sex at birth
none of it makes sense look this whole
this whole idea of the modern
transgender movement and by the way
something they don't tell you that we
learned in college the john money uh
twin sex study this is about you know he
had twins and he raised one as a boy one
as a girl right to show that gender was
a social construct they don't tell you
that
the guy sexually abused his kids put
them in sexually dominant positions and
the kids both one ended up killing
himself uh and i think the other one
died of a drug overdose i know that i
know that both are dead they don't tell
you how it ended up yeah and by the way
they don't tell you that it's
representative of how a lot of the
people and i say this with a heavy heart
who you're watching in these online
conferences statistically will end up
that's a statistical reality and it's
not because walmart won't let you take a
dump in the bathroom that you want
american slaves jews in the holocaust
didn't have the same kind of suicide
rate we are not being compassionate by
lying to people and enabling something
that flies in the face of biology and by
the way we know beyond any shadow of a
doubt that the way you would treat these
people flying in the face of scientific
biology being redundant saying
scientific biology giving them hormones
that would
put them to unnatural levels in the male
body for example of estrogen or in the
case of women testosterone we know it's
bad
we know there are increased cancer risks
sure they do the word placebo we don't
have long-term studies all right let me
ask you this hey by the way comment
below women who are watching and i have
a good friend of mine who just went in
for a double mastectomy this week god
lover the surgery's going surgery went
well
um and then they do the thing where they
take some of your fat and they put it up
there and she was very nervous i said
well just look at it this way you get
you get a pair of free tits and
liposuction she was like well that's
better
it's true it's all framing yeah that's
true
um
this
i don't even remember i'm so upset about
what was i saying before i was talking
about the double mastectomy oh yeah uh
what do you do with breast cancer
what's one of the first things they do
if women comment if you had breast
cancer
what do they give you
[Music]
radiation oh wait there's arimidex
they give you aromatase inhibitors they
give you estrogen blockers
because they know what estrogen does and
they know it's relation to cancer
including by the way in women
let alone in men
and then it got used on the black market
for bodybuilders in the very bonds
because they would take these drugs that
would raise their testosterone levels to
abnormal levels which would increase
their estrogen so they said let's use
these estrogen blockers which are often
used for
like breast cancer patients
let's use that to raise our testosterone
to super physiological doses without
having the sort of feedback loop of
estrogen it's what they will give to you
if you're a woman
right they're very concerned about
estrogen as it relates to cancer and we
know that it's not good for men i mean
for context you know men have about 20
times the levels of testosterone that a
woman does i don't know the ratio of
estrogen i would assume it's somewhere
in a multiple similar of women having
higher estrogen than men and even with
women you have to be very careful in
controlling it when giving a boy puberty
blockers and estrogen pills we say we
don't have long-term studies okay i get
it because no one has decided that they
want to step on that land mine because
they know the results who's going to pay
for those who's going to pay for those
long-term studies who's going to pay for
the long-term studies where they know
the answer is going to come back cancer
no one they don't want to perform them
they want to be able to say in
perpetuity we don't have long-term
studies that's why
but trust the science
i want to be compassionate
look
this is a bad bad place is a bad place
where we are and i will tell you a large
part of this it stems from feminism and
it stems from the feminization of young
boys and that was where we started
blurring gender lines and we have run
into a scenario where men have been brow
beaten toxic masculinity and so what
happens is you know what we can just all
be whatever notice that the trans female
to males aren't that masculine and the
males to females aren't masculine notice
the one thing you don't see in any of
these is masculinity
it's the one thing that's absent and i
don't just mean the father who didn't go
on a field trip with his uh
daughter transgender daughter into the
woods to the sounds of screams of their
ancestor i don't just mean that a father
was absent in that scenario
there are no dads here there are no men
here
hey
is there some importance that men bring
to the table and i'm not just talking
about the fact that it's uh the most
important statistical contributor to
kids graduating high school kids ending
up uh you know having successful
relationships successful financial lives
of their own uh gra not ending up in
prison i'm not just talking about a dad
in the house as it relates to that is
there value to in any of these
discussions having a man
have you noticed that there is not one
yeah there's not one there's men who
want to be women and there's women who
claim to be a man by saying my mustache
my back deck yeah that's a that's how i
was taught by my father to become a man
right he said son come sit on my knee
let me teach you what it is to be a man
it's a a belly a chin strap beard and a
big dick
a nose ring and a rainbow cowboy scarf
yes exactly as the scriptures say yes
video evidence of insanity that will be
used against you in a court of law this
all stems from i'm sorry you say
patriarchy what you really want to do is
get rid of men period and i'm not saying
that men are more important than women
i'm not saying that men are more
valuable than women i'm not saying that
they're better than women i'm saying
that men are needed also
how about that can we find common ground
there because that's one thing that i'm
not seeing here
and it's a through line
and it's remarkably consistent all right
speaking of lack of men i don't know if
you know this it's a huge contributor to
crime
but i just want to say do how much i
agree with you on that and they're all
reaching for a dad you notice that yep
every one of them it's the same as go to
your parents bank account and send me
money you're all asking for a father in
every video right wandering into the
woods alone not having your parents
there not having someone who cared about
you every one of them is asking for a
parent yeah and you didn't have it and
you know what this is the negative when
we talk about toxic masculinity
by that i mean the left this idea that
you're you know protect protect your
provider yeah that is that is primarily
the role of a man well guess what you
need right now you're talking about
violent crime being committed against
transgender individuals and by the way
that's because in disproportionate
amount of them work in sex work and
there's a huge amount of violent crime
that takes place there it's not
happening in the population at large but
you want a protector and then you want
reparations you want a provider
sooner or later you run out of
protectors and providers a lot of people
don't know this this is one thing too
um
men
particularly the men that you want
in the times of need in the times of
conflict
i get it they're not easy to live with
when you're not in that period of time
do you know how long it was
before winston churchill was ousted
after he defeated the nazis
someone can fact check me i'm pretty
sure it was within two years it's
relatively quickly yeah do you know why
you've told me and i don't remember
because they didn't support socializing
now a big part of his justification they
don't tell you is uh because he was
saying look we're going to basically if
we create this kind of a if we create
this kind of a a social safety net
system we're going to be a nation unable
to protect ourselves from the next great
that threat the government isn't it's
not a difference to provide people with
free things it's our job to protect the
people ah that's just churchill but
guess what happened when the nazis were
at their door they said we don't want
this chamberlain prick all right
churchill sure is hard to deal with
but we need him bring him that man who
you reach for when you need him
is usually someone who gets pushed aside
when you say oh yeah we don't need him
now just
pay alimony just be a checkbook just
come in and fight off the other evil men
and then once we're at a time like it's
like sweden
sweden with nato
we don't believe in we don't believe in
oh wait russia is can we join nato now
well it seems that it seems that you
have a great deal of uh back payments
dude
what's that 800 mile eastern border that
we have oh russia crap
yeah that's the largest border with
russia in europe enjoy your shitty fish
yeah by the way you know what dads do as
well and one of the reasons that we're
dealing with so many problems
is they impart identity into boys and
girls their kids they impart that
identity in a way that moms don't like
they've studied this this is something
that a dad can uniquely do and when
they're not in the home is it any wonder
that kids grow up not knowing who they
are and running to the most
safe kind of comfortable ideology that
they can find like the woods with
screams well in that case i mean that
makes what kind of a neighborhood do you
live in where that's the best you have
he gravitated towards safety
right now like you onto something right
you feel like you belong or that gives
you an identity and in this group you
can see it they're asking for approval
from everybody in that video every
single time it's this is who i really am
you love me right
and if that group as a whole said i love
you but this is bad for you
how many people would be making changes
but instead we've been told you have to
say oh that's beautiful and brave that's
fantastic that's exactly who you are
that's your truth and here's the thing
just so you know and people get mad at
me for this everyone who we just watched
look if i if you were to watch this
right now i do love you
i don't want bad things for you
but when you start targeting children
now my love for children is more
important than my love for you the i can
love you both but understand that
children need to be protected and do you
also notice that these people they love
to invoke eastern philosophy and yin and
yang what is that okay let's look what
does ying and yang mean
how would that relate to sexuality how
would it relate to gender
you need both
it's not yang and blur
it's there's a ying there's a yang they
fit together almost like
men and women don't say it
men and women ac dc
dnv whereas you refer to it rape
well also you were probably targeted as
a child that's why you're like that yeah
yeah you and you grew up obviously these
people are young they're younger than we
are yep so you grew up in a system where
all you knew was how to be liked by a
click of a button right so your entire
identity is based on what the internet
did yeah through which people were just
liking your [ __ ] so part of my language
for them
but for you to be like too like that's
it it didn't come down to any sort of
realism it just came down as a trade
system right and it also
and it created a system of appealing to
creeps exactly appealing to creeps who
wouldn't be allowed to troll the grade
school right are now able to click like
and send you a private message yeah and
you act as though that's a legitimate
relationship and this is where we are
now i was on uh you know i i only have
these memberships because i have to
review films for you guys i have to be
aware of what's going on so hold the
anger i get it with the disney
subscription yeah
it's a celebrate pride month yeah why in
the hell do children need to celebrate
pride month why
well it's even worse than this disney
had a cartoon with two male dinosaurs
that had a rock egg yeah and basically
they were saying like oh they want to be
two loving dads they knew exactly what
was going on and they're like oh let's
go and get some some of the animals from
the whatever we've got some extra eggs
or whatever over here and they brought
them to the the two dads the two dad
dinosaurs well no wonder they're extinct
well chip and dale does not sound like a
straight couple no it doesn't well i
don't know
bangers i still laugh at chippendale the
jiminy crickets christmas special when
they get the best of donald duck yeah oh
my god everybody it's still it still
gets me laughing well look and we're in
i know we're over time we can we can we
can push that stuff i i think it's it's
helpful if you're cool with it we're at
about an hour no i think we should end
okay that's what's going on
look and this is something please by the
way sharing is caring so hit the share
button if you're watching this on
youtube right now we are going to play
what the flag we had two separate
segments completely prepared for today
on the golden state of crime and the
recall that's happening in san francisco
um
we can talk about that tomorrow i i do
think
unfortunately you get people who want to
show you how much more they know than
you and you get this from conservatives
as well and they say well maybe they
want to deal on the whole weird gender
stuff but i want to deal with policy
these were some of the first policies
enacted by this president when you're
looking at what he did with the military
wanted to make it a priority for
transgenders to be open in the military
and now wants to punish schools
for not allowing intergender bathrooms
sorry not inter-gender bathrooms boys to
be in girls rooms let's be really clear
about that by the way after sex the
reason for this the reason it spurred it
keep in mind was uh what had happened
and i always forget the name of the
school district there in virginia
yeah someone was sexually assaulted in
the bathroom right and so parents were
outraged but then there was the response
from the left saying hey we can't allow
this outrage to paint us in a negative
light we need to make sure that people
know it's a right to go into any
bathroom that you want and what was run
up the flagpole to the former vice
president oh great i'll use my exec i'll
use my executive authority to uh
withhold funding from schools if they
don't allow uh the scenario that could
potentially lead to more situations like
london county and have to be really
careful because we also had an episode
removed
when we discussed rape having taken
place potentially potentially at some
point
by setting an actual specific example
right uh in a female prison well don't
worry the justice department was
dispatched to look into the backgrounds
of these angry parents at these school
board meetings yes yeah to make sure
that everything was okay with this
domestic terror threat that they were
dealing with and they contracted the uh
they co-contracted the black trans
justice league
well which
wanted to rest and didn't do anything
yeah so not to mention the uh the
organization attraction formerly known
as friction their plot to kidnap a
michigan governor yes yes and tree
people yes running to the trees running
to the streams of the trees yes
what else do you write i mean i can't
imagine being a child is that in here
like i hear screams from the ground and
so i ran into the woods
and i said mother did you do you hear it
and she said no and i said i'm gonna go
find it and she's like yeah go find the
screen perhaps it's my father good luck
yeah all right we're going to play what
the flag in this same theme uh on mug
club there's no way we could i i think
this will still be on youtube this show
it's possible
if we do just so you know if we do if
you don't see us here again one more
time because we are also dealing with a
[ __ ] privacy violation for someone
who sat down consented to change my mind
no idea if that's going to be a heart
strike from youtube
we've reached out to them legally to say
can you clarify this and sometime today
i don't know if the hammer is going to
come down so go to rumble uh you can
watch us there monday through thursday
at 10 a.m eastern and of course july
we're not going to be here we're going
to be july there will be a break for a
significant period of time so that we
can actually build up a new studio do
all this work here uh and i think i'm in
spokane washington uh you are doing like
six shows at some point in july i don't
know it's uh the spokane comedy club i
don't know yeah
it's a great room okay you guys can go
check it out it's not on the website
we'll announce our fall tour and
cultural appropriation month coming up
this thursday we still have a show
tomorrow yes we do but you know it's
south africa so get your costumes ready
uh
youtube i'm trying to think
if there's any you know what i mean from
today take your pick right now piss off
[Music]
you